we're going to do the first kumitachi
so we're going to do the cream attaches
and the variations if we do the first
kim attack for you as soon as i know
he's about to move i sense that
so
this is mental
you'll be watching the technical
because you can't feel
the mental
so when he when i left here this is this
he's ken
the energy from his pen to me i fell i
sensed
so the higher the grade
i want you to start looking at not the
but the feeling that you should be
getting from it if i if i move my cane
up and down like this slowly but i'm
projecting my
my
energy i'm projecting my coat view if i
do this nigel should feel that going up
and down his west bone
and you might go class a bit sensitive
but that's really
oh sensei's said they're already
defeated before they attacked me
it's because he sensed it he almost knew
the person better than they may have
known themselves
so so the technical
when that turns it's almost like inside
me turn it i feel that stir
i sense it i feel that stir
that makes this happen
and then i feel it again i feel that
that operates me
that operates me to do this
so i don't really need to look at him
because in the end i'm sort of wired to
them
so depending on your level
you'll be either doing technical
ah
and that's as far as it'll go it'll just
be boom boom boom nice and clean and
technical or
it'll be what i consider spiritual but
it's mental
really
you may not see a difference but me and
nigel know that there's a different
atmosphere between us
and that's about the only words i can
use right so we're going to look at the
first two hitachi those who don't know
it
okay
so
i didn't see anybody doing what i call
the mental side or the spiritual side i
actually was too busy doing clink clink
clink clunk
all right so but that doesn't matter i'm
just telling you that that's where you
should be aiming you know over the
rainbow aim for that it becomes
harmonious
powerful
hey
now
the next stage of the mental part is
i was the same fairly even if i growled
and grunted and shouted
my own persona wasn't bothered and i
wasn't trying to win on either one
so this is the mental thing now i'm just
going to talk about that so here
i see his head ah i want to cut it in
half
yes i won that one
that's how it says actually though
might be you know it's got no senses
it should have nothing
no want no no
one to me
shouldn't have none of that in it but
nor should the rest of it
the rest of it should be
yes i won
i was on target i'm good
right so it's a bit robotic
but you've moved to another dimension
you know you've moved to a harmonious
place
so it becomes like not me beautiful but
the the feeling the flow is beautiful
oh
yeah
up
once you understand that
you'll start to know that the
that is better than the winning
well that's that means that you're the
attacker
[Music]
if you get connected mentally
instead of jumping in here
instead of something like creepy
and winning
it will be like you've got a cord that's
not seen between you but you sense it
and we're gonna do it slowly
watch this
you see the shape was already there i
just had to shape it with his arm
so i've got lots of time
look
wherever he finishes that's the position
if i now expand my persona my co-cue
instead of me ending up
in a comfortable position
because that's all it becomes
it leaves him
here that leaves him strong so when i go
to press he'll go no
he's solid
so
those of you who done aikido for more
than 20 years
uh i'm doing a so i'm going to
enter
you
he's not strong because i took over the
center
at my feeling wasn't to win it was just
to
expand and be there
with my energy going out
right a lot of information there but
if he pushes in
you you've got comfortable balance they
haven't
all right so i'd like you to just try
that little piece when you're there and
don't get disappointed if you go oh i
thought i was stronger than i was but
i'm not but don't get disappointed that
often happens
yup
this will vary so somebody will ask me a
question again and say scentsy why don't
you step in this time sensei why did you
step out that time
whatever he does i'm the puppet
i'm the puppet of the attacker
all right
there's the second one
whatever he does
technically
i was too far down the can on his arm
if i throw out now my coke you or my
spirit what do you want to call it
then i'll stop
i'm okay because i'm over here all right
all right so if he cut straight
straight
yeah that's the second one
if you have the winning
attitude
or you haven't got that far yet in
danger levels
ah
they
go in and they try and control the elbow
if you do that i'd like uk
uchi and okay i'm okay this one with the
weapons we swapped walls
here at the end
up if you do this
i'd like
okay
to test your ability with his arm and
see if
he comes in both hands
if you're going to come down and see how
hard you've got
use strength to hold him off
because it shouldn't
take strength so your aim is
hey
your aim is here
okay so your aim is
impenetrable you are impenetrable
because you're not trying to win you're
just extending
so this should be tons of information
for everybody there
i just want to talk about some things
that have gone through my
my history of my thinking
is holding his ken wrong
yeah he's not quite on the right posture
john i mean i'm
we we seem to be really good at
thinking about what
they've got wrong with them
so anyway we'll do this and we'll go
okay he didn't really enter enough but
carry on
up i'm thinking about all this i'm going
to really finish him off now i'll wake
him up
ah
i'm the boss
my aikido is better than yours
so
you know
i don't know whether you've ever had
that i'm sure you haven't because you're
very good people
but that's the sort of
you know stages i've gone through so i
pretty much know all the stages there
are
if i just go
on what i consider the spiritual level
would not really care about his but just
think about the harmony
ha
hey
you do that
and you're in a complete empty void
it can be quite boring at certain levels
but it can be very rewarding at others
because you can now go
i was so concentrating on being in
harmony that i was actually tense
so you can actually start looking at
yourself
you can start looking about the person
you are
and how you want to think
i need to ease that one myself i'm
beating myself up here and i'm not
enjoying the aikido because i'm more
worried about
getting all the
feelings right
hey
ah
up
so now i've decided to move the scale a
little bit to be sharper
and i'm in between
what i call spiritual and technical
because i was beating myself up mentally
too much on the spiritual side
and now i'll go the other end on the
technical side
and then i gotta go
i enjoyed that little bit didn't i and
that was wrong
so
so you're never gonna be right
and that's why
as i say nearly 50 years of training
that's why i'm still doing it because i
haven't mastered it yet
or who am i trying to master but i'm
enjoying the ride on the way
and that's that's the wonderful thing